so what if I could make for you a
designer baby what if you as a parent to
be and I as a scientist decided to go
down that road together what if we
didn't what if we thought you know we
thought that's a bad idea that many of
our family friends and co-workers did
make that decision let's fast forward
just 15 years from now let's pretend
it's the year 2030 and you're a parent
you have your daughter Marion next to
you and in 2030 she is what we call
unnatural because she has no genetic
modifications and because you and your
partner consciously made that decision
many in your social circle they kind of
look down on you they think you're like
a Luddite or a technophobe Marion's best
friend Jenna who lives right next door
is a very different story she was born a
genetically modified designer baby with
numerous upgrades yeah upgrades and
these enhancements were introduced using
a new genetic modification technology
that goes by the funny name
CRISPR you know like something's crisped
this is CRISPR the scientist that
Jenna's parents hired to do this for
several million dollars introduced
CRISPR into a whole panel of human
embryos and then they used genetic
testing and they predicted that that
little tiny embryo Jenna's embryo would
be the best of the bunch
and now jenna is an actual real person
she's sitting sitting on the carpet in
your living room playing with your
daughter Marian and your families have
known each other for years now and has
become very clear to you the jenna is
extraordinary
she's incredibly intelligent if you're
honest with yourself she's smarter than
you and she's five years old she's
beautiful tall athletic and the list
goes on and on and in fact there's a
whole new generation of these GM kids
like Jenna and so far it looks like
they're healthier than their parents
generation than your generation and they
have lower health care costs they're
immune to a host of health conditions
including hiv/aids and genetic diseases
it all sounds so grave but you can't
help but have this sort of unsettling
feeling a gut feeling that there's
something just not quite right about
Jenna you've had the same feeling about
other GM kids that you've met you're
also reading in the newspaper earlier
this week that a study of these children
who were born as designer babies
indicates they may have some issues like
increased aggressiveness and narcissism
but more immediately on your mind is
some news that you just got from Jenna's
family she's so smart she's now going to
be going to a special school a different
school than your daughter Marian and
this is kind of throwing your family
into in a disarray Marion's been crying
and last night when you took her to bed
to kiss her good night she said daddy
well Jenna you can be my friend anymore
so now as I've been telling you this
imagine 20 30 storia I have a feeling
that I might have put some of you into
this like sci-fi frame of reference
right you think you're reading a sci-fi
book or maybe like in Halloween you know
mode of thinking but this is really a
possible reality for us just 15 years
from now I'm a stencil and genetics
researcher and I can see this new CRISPR
technology and its potential impact and
we might find ourselves in that reality
and a lot will depend on what we decide
to do today and if you're still kind of
thinking in sci-fi mode
consider that the world of science had a
huge shock earlier this year and the
public largely doesn't even know about
it
researchers in China just a few months
ago reported the creation of genetically
modified human embryos this is the first
time in history and they did it using
this new CRISPR technology it didn't
work perfectly but I still think they
sort of cracked the the door ajar on a
Pandora's Box here and I think some
people are going to run with this
technology and try to make designer
babies now before I go on some of you
may sort of hold up your hands and say
stop all wait a minute you know isn't
wouldn't that be illegal right you can't
just go off and create a designer baby
and in fact to some extent you're right
in some countries you couldn't do that
but in many other countries including my
country the US there's actually no law
on this so in theory you could do it
there was another development this year
that resonates in this area and that
happened not so far from here over in
the UK and the UK traditionally has been
the strictest country when it comes to
human genetic modification it was
illegal there but just a few months ago
they carved out an exception to that
rule
they passed a new law allowing the
creation of genetically modified humans
with the noble goal of trying to prevent
a rare kind of genetic disease but still
I think in combination these events are
pushing us further towards for an
acceptance of human genetic modification
so I've been talking about this CRISPR
technology what actually is CRISPR so if
you think about the GMOs that we're all
more familiar with like GMO Tomatoes and
wheat and things like that
this technology is similar to the
technologies that were used to make
those but it's dramatically better
cheaper and faster so what is it it's
actually like a genetic Swiss Army knife
we can pretend this is a Swiss Army
knife with different tools in it and one
of the tools is kind of like
a magnifying glass or a GPS for our DNA
so it can home in on a certain spot and
the next tool is like a scissors that
can cut the DNA right in that spot and
finally we have a pen where we can
literally rewrite the genetic code in
that location it's really that simple
and this technology which came on the
scene just three years ago has taken
science by storm it's evolving so fast
and it's so freaking exciting the
scientist and I admit I'm fascinated by
it and we use it in my own lab that I
think someone's going to go that extra
step and continue the GM human embryo
work and maybe make designer babies this
is so ubiquitous now just you know came
on the scene three years ago thousands
of labs literally have this in hand
today and they're doing important
research most of them are not interested
in designer babies they're studying you
know human disease and other important
elements of science there's a lot of
good research going on with CRISPR and
the fact that we can now do genetic
modifications that used to take years
and cost millions of dollars in a few
weeks
for a couple thousand bucks to me as a
scientist that's fantastic but again at
the same time it opens the door to
people going too far and I think for
some people the focus is not going to be
so much on science that's not what's
going to be driving them it's going to
be ideology or chase for a profit and
they're going to go for designer babies
so why should we be you know why be
concerned about this we know from Darwin
you know if we go back to centuries the
evolution and genetics profoundly have
impacted humanity who we are today
and some think there's like a social
Darwinism at work in our world and maybe
even a eugenics as well imagine those
trends those forces with a booster
rocket of this CRISPR technology that is
so powerful and so ubiquitous
in fact we can just go back one century
to the last century to see the power
that eugenics can have so my father
Peter knopfler was actually born right
here in Vienna he was Viennese and he
was born here in 1929 and when my
grandparents had little baby Peter the
world was very different right it was a
different Vienna the United States was
different the world was different
there was a eugenics rising and my
grandparents realized pretty quickly I
think that they were on the wrong side
of the eugenics equation and so despite
this being their home and their whole
extended family's home and this whole
this area you know being their family's
home for generations they decided
because of eugenics that they had to
leave and they survived but they were
heartbroken and I'm not sure my dad ever
really got over leaving you know he left
when he was just eight years old
in 1938 so today I see a new eugenics
kind of bubbling to the surface it's
supposed to be a kinder gentler positive
eugenics different you know than all
that past stuff but I think even though
it's focused on trying to improve people
it could have negative consequences and
it really worries me that some of the
top proponents of this new eugenics they
think CRISPR is the ticket to make it
happen so I have to admit you know
eugenics you know we talk about making
better people it's a tough question of
what is better when we're talking about
a human being but I admit I think maybe
a lot of us could agree that you know
human beings maybe we could use a little
better rent you know look at our
politicians here you know back in the
u.s. god forbid we go there right now
you know maybe even if we just look in
the mirror there might be ways we think
blue you know we could be better you
know I might wish honestly that I had
more hair here you know instead of
baldness some people might wish there
were taller have a different weight you
know a different face
if we could do those things we could
make those things happen or we could
make them happen in our children it
would be very seductive and yet coming
with it would be these risks I talked
about eugenics but there would be risk
to individuals as well so if we forget
about enhancing people and we just try
to make them healthier using genetic
modification this technology is so new
and so powerful that by accident we
could make them sicker you know if that
easily could happen and there's another
risk and that is that all of the
legitimate important genetic
modification research going on just in
the lab again no interest in designer
babies a few people going the designer
baby route things go badly that entire
field could be damaged I also think it's
not that unlikely that governments might
start taking an interest in genetic
modification so for example our imagined
GM Jena child who is healthier if
there's a generation that looks like
they have lower health care costs it's
possible that governments may start
trying to compel their citizens to go to
the GM route look at China's one-child
policy it's thought that that prevented
the birth of 400 million human beings so
it's not you know beyond the realm of
possible that genetic modification could
be something that governments push and
if designer babies become popular you
know in our digital age viral videos
social media what if designer babies are
thought to be fashionable and they kind
of become the new glitterati right the
new Kardashians or something you know
are those trends that we really could
control you know I'm not convinced that
we could so again today Halloween and
when we talk about genetic modification
there's one Halloween associated
character that is talked about or
invoked more than anything else and that
is Frankenstein right mostly that's been
you know frankenfoods and all this other
stuff
but if we if we think about this now and
we think about in the human context on a
day like Halloween if parents can in
essence costume their children
genetically you know are we going to be
talking about Frankenstein 2.0 kind of
situation I don't think so I don't think
it's going to get to that extreme but
when we are going about hacking the
human code I think all bets are off in
terms of what might come about there
would still be dangers and we can look
in the past two other elements of
transformative science and see how they
can basically go out of control and
permeate society so I'll just give you
one example and that is in vitro
fertilization exactly almost exactly
forty years ago test-tube baby number
one Louise Brown was born and that's a
great thing and I think since then five
million IVF babies have been born bring
it immeasurable happiness a lot of
parents now can love those kids but if
you think about it in four decades five
million babies being born from a new
technology is pretty remarkable and the
same kind of thing can happen with human
genetic modification and designer babies
so depending on the decisions we make in
the next few months the next year or so
if designer baby number one is born
within a few decades there could well be
millions of genetically modified humans
and there's a difference there too
because if we you know you in the
audience or I if we decide to have a
designer baby then their children will
also be genetically modified and so on
because it's heritable so that's a big
difference so with all of this in mind
you know what should we do there's
actually going to be a meeting a month
from tomorrow in Washington DC by the US
National Academy of Sciences to tackle
that exact question what is the right
path forward with human genetic
modification I believe at this time we
need a moratorium we have to ban this we
should not allow creating genetically
modified people because it's just too
dangerous and too unpredictable but
there's a lot of people
[Applause]
and let me say just as a scientist it's
a little bit scary for me to say that in
public because science you know
generally doesn't like self-regulation
and things like that so I think you know
we need to put a hold on this but there
are many people who not only disagree
with me they feel the exact opposite
they're like step on the gas
full speed ahead let's make designer
babies and so in the meeting in December
and other meetings that are likely to
follow in the next few months it's very
possible there may be no moratorium and
I think part of the problem that we have
is that all of this trend this
revolution in genetic modification
applying to humans the public hasn't
known about it nobody has been saying
look you know this is a big deal this is
a revolution and this could affect you
in very personal ways and so part of my
goal is actually to change that and to
educate and engage with the public and
get you guys talking about this and so I
hope at these meetings that there will
be a role for for the public you know to
bring their voice to bear as well so if
we kind of circle back now to 2030 again
that imagined story and depending on the
decisions we make again today literally
we don't have a lot of time in the next
few months the next year or so because
this technology is spreading like
wildfire let's pretend we're back in
that reality we're at a park and our kid
is swinging on the swing you know is
that kid a regular old kid or did we
decide to have a designer baby and let's
say we we went the sort of traditional
route and there's our kids swinging on
the swing and frankly you know they're
kind of a mess you know their hair is
all over the place like mine they have a
you know stuffy nose they're not the
best student in the world they're
adorable you love them but they're on
the swing next to them their best friend
is a GM kid and the two of them are kind
of swinging like this and you can't help
but compare them right and the GM kid is
swinging higher they look better
there are better students they don't
have that stuffy nose you need to wipe
you know how is that going to make you
feel and what decision let you make next
time thank you
[Applause]